nous sommes nous avec pascal mousset
restaurateurs et président du génie
paris ile de france qui représente donc
les indépendants de l'hôtellerie et de
la restauration bonsoir pascal mousset
merci d'être avec nous on a vu vos
collègues lyonnais allaient manifester
se battre dans la rue
vous pensez que ça va porter ses fruits
de faire entendre la colère est ce que
vous croyez encore possible une
réouverture le 12 novembre comme vous
l'appeliez devant veut il ya quelques
temps encore en fait on l'espère
aujourd'hui ce qu'on voudrait c'est
avoir des perspectives c'est vrai que 12
novembre on n'est pas très nombreux et y
croire parce que traditionnellement avec
cette crise sanitaire on a appris à être
les premiers à fermer les restaurants et
avec les dernières ouvrir parce que
l'argument sanitaire qui nous est
invoquée c'est qu'il faut retirer le
masque pendant le la prestation que ce
soit dans un bar ou dans un resto
aujourd'hui ce qu'il nous faut c'est des
perspectives on peut pas rester comme ça
sonne moins fermé et n'avoir aucune
perspective
aucune date ne pas savoir comment
organiser ces fêtes de fin d'année si
nos restaurants seront fermées pendant
les fêtes et se trouve aidera la merci
économiquement de nos créanciers des
banques des bailleurs des assureurs de
tout ce qui tournait et qui qui en fait
on devient une proie et ont deux
extrêmement fragilisée avec ses cinq
mois d'absence de chiffre d'affaires et
surtout aucune perspective
aucune entreprise ne peut survivre sans
avoir l'espoir une date un moment où
elle va pouvoir réenclencher une
activité ça quand vous l'expliqué très
clairement parce que ça semble tellement
plein de bon sens que vous nous dites
quand vous l'expliquer aux pouvoirs
publics
concrètement vous réponds quoi
concrètement aujourd'hui dans ce pays
comme dans beaucoup de pays dans le
monde
je je je pense pas la critique sur notre
gouvernement je dis simplement que la
santé n'a pas de prix
est ce que nous l'ont craint c'est
d'être d'être stigmatisés et que bien au
delà de la crise sanitaire
il reste quelque chose de ce doigt
pointé sur nos métiers de service qu'ils
s'agissent de traiteur d'hôtellerie et
de restauration
on a pendant toute cette année dit c'est
dangereux 1 de façon subliminale 1 on a
fait comprendre aux anneaux
consommateurs c'était dangereux de
fréquenter nos établissements et je
pense que le plan de relance qui va nous
est proposé il doit être absolument
ciblées sur nos professions et il doit
être concentrée sur les grandes
métropoles parce que je vous rappelle
que les grandes métropoles françaises
leur envoyer mes confrères lyonnais mais
on pourrait parler de cannes sur tout
paris que je représente
paris est une ville monde 1 100
touristes paris regardez aujourd'hui
votre confrère des échos qui est quand
même parmi le journal le plus sérieux
sur le plan économique il annonce la
disparition de 50 % des restaurants le
journal les échos il parle de 90000
restaurants qui vont disparaître
il faut quand même mesurer l'impact
économique mais aussi l'impact social
derrière que ce confinement va produire
j'ai seulement la disparition d'un
restaurant sur deux vous vous
l'expliquez comment les aides ne sont
pas assez fortes parce qu'on a beaucoup
parlé de cet accompagnement mais dans le
concret ça ne se passe pas aussi
facilement ou c'est un dispositif qui a
été peut-être mal évalué tout simplement
mais je pense que quand on a fait nos
demandes le dispositif était très bien
calibrée lors du pro
confinement mais personne n'a imaginé
que cette crise allait durer aussi
longtemps
là on envisage maintenant qu'on va aller
jusque plus d'un an de crise sanitaire
donc d'empêchement de travail et de
l'est les pancartes que vous venez de
voir ces laissez nous travailler on est
plutôt on n'est pas habitué on va faire
des demandes aide on est habitué à se
lever le matin et travailler dans nos
professions
aujourd'hui pour pas rentrer dans un
débat technique on est à la merci de nos
bailleurs parce qu aucune loi qui peut
imposer un propriétaire de restaurant
d'hôtel à abandonner une partie du loyer
il ya une incitation fiscale mais qui
n'a pas force de loi et le bailleur en
face de nous il peut dire moi je veux
pas le savoir vous me payer mon loyer
vous n'ayez pas pu travailler c'est pas
mon problème
on est face à ce problème là qu'un
problème immense parce que 70 % des
frais qui continue à courir quand nous
n'avons pas la possibilité de travailler
sont constitués par les loyers est le
deuxième sujet on a des centaines de
milliers de collaborateurs qu'on n'a pas
pu faire venir au travail parce que nous
étions soit fermées soit on avait des
jauges qu'il limitait dans nos activités
ils ont accumulé les droits aux congés
payés c'est le droit du travail et ses
droits aux congés payés constitue une
véritable bombe à retardement qui va
falloir honoré et financièrement au
printemps et à l'été prochain et les
entreprises qui auront plus passer la
première étape du bailleur se trouveront
condamné par la seconde étape économique
est en cessation de paiement quand il va
falloir décaissé ses congés payés et on
est une industrie de manoeuvre comme le
bâtiment donc chez nous les salaires
représentent souvent 40 à 50 % de notre
activité faut mesurer quand même c'est
une charge énorme les pouvoirs publics
en ont pris conscience mais n'ont pas de
solution à nous proposer ce jour comment
vous avez vécu l'antre-2 confinement si
j'ose dire parce que clairement les
clients sont revenus non dans les
restaurants il y avait une envie qui
c'est qui s'est matérialisé qui s'est
concrétisée de façons très différentes
suivant que vous étiez dans une zone
touristique une zone de villégiature à
la campagne en bord de mer à la montagne
ça s'est plutôt bien passé et mes
confrères qui ont travaillé
juin juillet août ont pu retrouver une
activité normale voire supérieur à
l'accoutumée par contre dans les grandes
métropoles dans les grandes villes paris
lyon et lille beaucoup de villes de
métropole il faut les appeler comme ça
notamment celles qui sont tournées
internationales n'ont pas repris du tout
une activité normale
a paris nous sommes restés à 50% de
baisse en moyenne dans les restaurants
et des 80 % de baisse et chez des
traiteurs jusqu'à 100 % d'activité qui
ont disparu donc ya pas eu vraiment de
reprise dans les grandes métropoles
c'est pour ça que ce second confinement
avec son couvre-feu du 16 octobre et ces
fermetures du 30 octobre
on les a vécues dans les grandes villes
comme un coup de grâce
parce que on sait très bien que dans les
grandes villes ce sera beaucoup plus
compliqué de repartir alors il ya encore
pire pour vous si vous passez cette
expression ce sont les discothèques qui
n'ont jamais pu rouvrir
est-ce que vous avez des nouvelles vous
vous communiquez avec entre nîmes et ses
collègues
deux boîtes de nuit elles ont disparu
aujourd'hui ses discothèques en france
car elles ont bénéficié d'un dispositif
qui leur a permis pour beaucoup d'entre
elles d'honorer ses charges de loyer
donc certaines sont en sommeil certaines
ne rouvriront pas aujourd'hui il est
clair que la durée de cette crise
si si c'est pas sur le plan économique
c'est sur le plan moral que les chefs
d'entreprise ne vont pas pouvoir
reprendre
on leur a coupé les fils pierre on leur
a coupé toute envie de se battre pour
payer les dettes qu'ils ont accumulés
parce qu'il faut bien mesurer que ces
entreprises si elles repartent demain
c'est avec un fardeau énorme de dettes
qu'elles ont accumulés par un an de
fermeture hâtive chefs d'entreprise ne
veulent pas se voir cinq années à à la
merci des banquiers et à travailler
juste pour honorer des dettes il faut
bien mesurer que il y a une dimension
économique mais une dimension également
psychologique à cette crise merci avant
parce qu'elles ont fait d'avoir été avec
nous restaurateurs président du génie
paris ile de france qui représente donc
les indépendants de l'hôtellerie et de
la restauration merci à vous